C'est ouf, genre les handspinners la mode est déjà passée quoi.
Mais grave... j'avais oublié.
8 minutes ça a duré, je crois.
Complètement oublié, ce truc !
Ca vous dit on va se bouffer un petit truc vite fait ?
Mais qu'est ce que t'as fait ?
Gars, c'est quoi cette coupe ?
J'ai demandé à mon coiffeur d'improviser et il a improvisé.
On dirait une coupe de viking !
Ouais ou une coupe tecktonik !
De quoi ?
De ... de tecktonik.
C'est quoi ?
Tu sais les gars, à l'époque, ils avaient tous les coupes de ouf comme ça ...
Il y avait une danse ça va vous revenir, attends.
Viens assieds-toi.
Il y avait genre... Tout le monde connaissait au moins un mouvement, quoi genre c'était des trucs avec les bras ...
Attendez, attendez.
Moi je trouve ça pas mal, quand même.
Ça va forcément vous rappeller quelque chose, il y avait des logos, des t-shirts ...
Un art martial son truc.
Désolé je dois filer, mangez sans moi, c'est pas grave.
Non non Ludo, refais ton truc avec les bras là, je fais une story.
Voilà.
Allez-y ! Allez-y monsieur ! Allez-y, allez-y.
Oh putain Ludo, comment ça va ?
Ouais ça va, juste, je peux te parler vite fait ?
Là je suis entrain de taffer, mais si tu veux on se voit après, on se prend un petit café ?
Vraiment juste 2 secondes, juste la tecktonik tu te souviens ou pas ?
Je ne vois pas de quoi tu parles.
Mais si, tu sais, la tecktonik ... La danse un petit peu... là tu sais comme ça, avec les moulinets.
Putain, mais t'es en train de faire une connerie, là !
Quoi ?
Tu veux avoir des problèmes ou quoi ?
Voilà donc ça existe la tecktonik, je suis pas fou, ça existe !
Non, ça n'a jamais existé.
Aller, circulez monsieur !
Circulez, s'il vous plaît !
Aller !
Circulez ...
Aller, avancez, avancez.
Voilà.
Allez-y, pas trop près.
Circulez.
Rémi ?
C'est ça, la tecktonik ...
Cours, Ludo.
Cours, Ludo ! Cours ! Ne t'arrête jamais de danser, tu m'entends !
Merde !
Mec faut que tu m'aides, je suis poursuivi et je crois qu'ils veulent me tuer !
Oh putain.
Calmez-vous ! Calmez-vous, on ne vous veut aucun mal.
Ah ouais ? Alors pourquoi vous avez sauté sur Rémi tout à l'heure ? Vous me prenez pour un con c'est ça ?
C'était pour son bien, ok ? Uniquement pour son bien.
Mais c'est quoi le problème avec la tecktonik là ?
Il n'y a pas de tecktonik hein, il n'y a jamais eu de tecktonik, tout ça c'est dans votre tête.
Ah ouais ? Et ça là, ça c'est dans la tête ?
On se calme.
Restez en position, le suspect devient dangereux.
Arrêtez-ça tout de suite, ok ?
Bah pourquoi ?
Je croyais que ça existait pas ? On s'en fout.
Monte !
Qu'est ce qui se passe, putain ?
T'inquiètes pas, tu vas vite comprendre !
Je peux savoir où on va maintenant, là ?
Ludo ... T'es pas fou.
La tecktonik existe bien.
La vérité c'est que l'Etat français a tellement honte de ce mouvement qu'ils ont décidé d'en effacer toutes les traces.
Ils ont décidé de punir tout ceux qui osent en parler.
Et neutraliser tous les derniers représentants de cet art.
Oh mon dieu et du coup il n'y en a plus, c'est ça ?
Bienvenu dans notre QG !
Alors ?
Incroyable.
Attendez, quel est le rapport avec moi ? Je veux dire ... Pourquoi je suis au courant de l'existence de la tecktonik ?
Parce que t'es l'un d'entre nous, Ludo.
Ou devrais-je dire... Ludoteck.
Quoi ?
T'étais l'un des meilleurs représentant de ce mouvement.
Un danseur de talent hors-pair.
Regarde, regarde cette fluidité dans tes mouvements.
T'es une anguille !
On a dû supprimer toute trace de ton passé pour te protéger.
Et quand je dis toute trace, ça inclus également ton skyblog.
Mais...
Tout est là.
C'est moi ?
Ouais.
Avec le tee-shirt ?
Et le jean ?
Non, là c'est Jack Da.
Ah, il est juste là.
Bonjour.
Toi t'es là, juste à droite.
Ah oui oui oui, bon la qualité est pas folle folle, mais oui oui je crois que c'est moi.
LUDOTECK.
T'es de retour parmi nous.
Grâce à toi, la tecktonik va connaître un second souffle.
Que personne ne bouge ! C'est donc ici votre petit QG ?
On a carrément recréé une petite discothèque à ce que je vois ...
S'en est fini, Ludoteck.
La tecktonik ne survivra pas.
Bon aller, rendez-vous si vous ne voulez pas que la situation dégénère, d'accord ?
Mais c'est pas possible ?
T'en fais pas va.
Je savais que ce moment arriverait.
Et je suis fier de le vivre à tes côtés, Ludoteck.
Il faut que j'arrête de vivre dans le passé... Et que je dise adieu à MSN.
Que je dise adieu à Myspace ...
Adieu... la Star Académie.
Adieu... adieu la tecktonik.
Je me rends !
Attends, attends.
Je me rends.
J'apprécie votre comportement et vous savez quoi ? On va vous réinsérer dans la société d'accord ? Et puis vous inquiétez pas il existe d'autre danse, comme la zumba par exemple.
On peut se battre avec la tecktonik ?
On peut se battre avec la tecktonik !